from the post-millennial Chuck Schumer
demands border never closes bill pass or
else US troops will have to fight in
Ukraine let's let's we're going to break
this down he did not literally say
Ukraine he said in Eastern Europe in a
NATO Ally in a few years and so it's
vague enough first he could mean Poland
he could mean Sweden I think it's fair
to argue he might literally mean Ukraine
in that the the West wants to take
control of it and would AB shove it into
NATO if if they had to but he's
basically saying Vladimir Putin is going
to invade Europe and so we need this
border security Bill whose border
security Ukraine's it's a Ukraine border
security I want to know how my border
got to Ukraine
you you know when we say how did our
freedoms get to the Middle East how how
did our border get to the ukra we now
fire them all bulldoze DC salt the earth
I truly I'm coming to believe this
hypothesis at least I have the
hypothesis that we are in a slow coup
that's been going on for 100 years man
it's like a banking yeah they're trying
to do it not fast enough to alert the
people JFK like JFK the Federal Reserve
the business plot the the there's so
much there's so many Foreign Wars that
are proxy wars where with money getting
laundered away from our country and like
I mean 911 even I could just go down a
list of things I find in my hypothesis
that this is a news show I'm not going
to do that on a news show but like the
the last 10 years it's been like they're
like make it don't alert them don't
alert them just let's get the money
let's do the co spending
what they increased our budget by like
20% our deficit by like 20% in like two
years this
look soft coup I mean there I I would
actually
suggest I I would ask at what point does
the government become the the the
functioning and in control government
right so uh Taiwan the official name of
Taiwan is what the Republic of China I
believe correct yeah and so many people
make the joke that communist China is
just west Taiwan because the original
government of China fled to Taiwan
they've maintained themselves ever since
resisting the Communists and so my
question is at what point after the coup
happened in the United States woodro
Wilson who knows the banker plot the
Federal Reserve 193 that's right so my
point is simply this maybe the
Revolution was Donald Trump not that he
is a perfect guy not that he was the guy
but that he ripped the establishment's
power in Twain and they were losing
their minds they're still losing it
absolutely and so when everyone's like
they're trying to Stage a I'm like you
know the thing is the establishment was
in control the uni party was in control
then a bunch of people on the internet
made a bunch of memes and the reality TV
Real Estate Mogul wins and says don't do
should to get down secure go borders and
then they lose their minds like we've
lost control of this that's why it's
funny when they say our democracy they
say Donald Trump is a threat to our
democracy they're literally saying that
there's a populist Uprising against the
autocratic control we've maintained for
Generations yep that's true it was um
George Bush senior in the 90s said that
we were moving towards a new world order
this liberal economic order was fading
into something new a global order um and
uh Trump got into office and canceled
the trans-pacific partnership right away
three days in it was the if you look at
the investor State dispute settlement
clause in that trans-pacific partnership
it said foreign countries these
investors these Malaysian oil companies
can sue a state for discrimination if we
chose not to buy a Malaysian compan oil
as American citizens they could sue our
country and as taxpayers we would have
had to pay a corporation out that's what
that trans-pacific partnership was going
to do to us and Obama was on board and
then Trump came in and threw in the
garbage I didn't even know if he knew
what it was what what it was doing I
don't know if he stopped something he
understood he just knew there were a
bunch of people outside yelling Trump
and they had expressed concerns about
let's not fool ourselves and act like
there's not so much foreign influence
today still in the United States though
I mean it's apac's arguably one of the
very strongest outside influences in the
United States today and it's you know
and it's not good for us as As Americans
especially when you're American first
person right um but Trump got into
office and immediately hired John Bolton
so I mean the establishment thing is
kind of no no I think Donald was not
great at Hing Donald Trump was really
bad understand Donald Trump thought he
was like I'll play ball and I'll get
done what I want to get done and they
were like no no no no no you don't
understand you live under our boot you
know they they the the the joke is you
know as soon as you win the election you
sit down in the Oval Office guy from the
CIA sits down and just hands him sits
down Mr President opens a middle of
folder and then slides a picture of JFK
right across the table and says we'll be
in touch and then leaves right we get it
we get it Trump is the guy who was like
what is this I don't know what you're
showing me why are you showing me a
picture of this guy and they're like um
we're letting you know letting me know
what I don't get it and they're like to
intimidate doesn't understand what I'm
trying to say to him he's like look
we're going to secure the Border we're
shutting down the no Mr President we're
not yes we are on the bus and he doesn't
listen yeah so what I what do I think is
I when when Trump was running I remember
I was in DC Trump had had a meeting with
a bunch of establishment Republicans
they did not want him the Democrats want
him to be the pi Piper candidate Trump I
think genuinely wants to secure the
borders bring jobs back that goes
against their agenda and so he thinks
when he gets in now I'm the president
I've got to play ball with some of these
guys I gotta you know there's favors
we'll bring in John Bolton I think
Sheldon Adin wanted a lot of a lot a lot
of favors absolutely and so then what
happens rushia gate and Trump I think
finally realizes bro you are being
tricked manipulated and lied to and you
brought in a bunch of dumb asses I don't
I question whether or not there is
whether there are
people in available to fill the
positions that are not currently like
already steeped in the bureaucracy right
like there are a lot of positions that
have to be filled and I don't know who
you go with that's actually someone
that's not you know that's not already
got their their you know significant
connections to to the existing
bureaucracy just because you conc but
Bolton is like
obviously let let me tell you in order
to hire John Bolton Trump had to drive
past a local prison drive past a city
dump all better people and go way way
down to the to the Pacific garbage gy
where he got a submersible and went down
to where all the deepest trenches of
garbage have sunk and dig even deeper
than that and there's John we could have
dug up the corpse of meline Albright it
would have been the same thing
essentially and so yeah it's it's
terrible and and and so that was what
worries me about Trump too right like in
in 2024 should Trump win is like is it
the same thing going to happen um and
yeah and then that's great and I get
that but my concern is that a lot of my
young Republican friends because I have
a lot of friends that are Republicans
tons of friends are very excited about
Trump because of who the VP pick might
be and I think everybody's like oh it's
got to be somebody like V or somebody
like uh Christy gome or somebody like
that and I'm like you realize that like
80 part of the 80% of the GOP is still
like deeply entrenched like neocons and
they have to play to that part of the
party not the 7% that like it would be
really funny if Trump just like came out
and was like I've chosen my VP John
Bolton
guy' I think it's gonna be somebody
along the lines of Nicky Haley I really
believe might Tucker man just I'll put
it simply for those that don't know uh
John Bolton has a long history of
working in administrations and just
wanting war and so he we had a quote uh
I think this was during the Trump
Administration he said something like
this time next year we will be
celebrating in tran
and so he is a he is just a neocon
maximalist warmonger character Nikki
Haley ain't got nothing on the war he
wants Trump hiring him was a mistake and
then Bolton stabbed him in the back yeah
you could do the like hire a cabinet of
a bunch of successful businessmen at
this point it's like like the founders
did the founding fathers were a bunch of
successful businessmen that got together
and started and ran a government
together because they knew what how to
run things and they weren't entrenched
in the garbage musk for VP I mean you're
talking about getting he's not born in
America if you're talking about getting
people that are actually going to
satisfy like supposedly the other side
of the aisle the last people they're
going to be satisfied with are people
that are that are like you know CEOs and
board members of compies you can't
satisfy the other side satisfy the other
side of the aisle I would agree with
that we we were talking about this uh
downstairs cuz this song came on by um
Passion Pit and there's a line he has a
song called I took a walk and there's a
line in the song where it says we can
rip apart all the the Socialists and all
their damn
texes and uh the left went nuts over the
song attacking the band and criticizing
them was like a cancel culture thing for
having dared said that and that the
point of the song though is it's about
the feelings of like his Elder his
relatives it's it's quotes from them and
things they have said he's not literally
saying he hat socialism he's just saying
like this is what the older guy said to
him but the left doesn't care what's
true they don't care about the point of
the statement or the message it's just
it's surface level it's it's it's one
one-dimensional thinking so if you want
to satisfy these people I mean we were
talking about this uh uh uh just before
the show and I mentioned it in the
morning segment about this guy I was
playing a poker and he had Trump
derangement syndrome down in DC and I
realized something my girlfriend had
said he was he was he was muttering to
himself he was screaming how could you
vote for Trump he would not listen to a
single word he asked me to name one
thing Trump did that I liked I said no
new Wars he keeps muttering he's like
you can't even name one thing I'm like
Abraham Accords he keeps muttering and
I'm like this guy can't a word he's just
sitting there they so stupid these
people are so dumb they're stupid and
then my girlfriend's like he doesn't
know what the Abraham Accords are and I
was like
ah there's no way for him to respond at
all to what that means because he
doesn't know you can't satisfy these
people because they live in a they live
in a shoe box but arguably besides the
no new Wars thing the best thing Trump
did was ex like make people extreme on
the corporate news media being the enemy
of the people I that's the greatest
thing that Trump did and and it was
hilarious watching him work I mean just
you know the way that he's able to just
troll people in in real life is amazing
like that's great I love that but I do I
worry about Trump too and what that
means for you know the people who get
their hopes up for a lot of stuff and
then it doesn't happen well in 2020 less
than half a million people came across
the border and were apprehended it was
less than half a
million yeah illegal immigrants in 2020
in what can you really expect from from
Donald Trump too like what what what
what is it that you think people are
expecting I I think well I think people
first of all the spot I think that a lot
of people are going to be let down when
we find out who the VP but that's not
even when he's president let's say he
gets elected and I don't know and you
know people are like oh it's going to be
somebody great I'm like do you remember
you remember who VP was last time I know
so let's let's say it's it's Trump
bergam I'm just picking like the least
probable candidate sure yeah what do
people think like what what what what
what do you perceive as the hopes and
dream I think I think on the extreme
side it's that you know all these people
are going to go to jail right like this
is this is the revenge tour we're going
to we're going to lock up all these
corrupt people and and shut down the
border and we're going to end all the
wars and we're going to you know give
all the tax cuts I know but that's what
a lot of people think no no no no but
like first I can locking people up and
arresting everybody maybe some people
might get some
referrals you don't think that some
people won't get arrested I sure hope so
I believe I don't think it's going to be
like military tribunals where they go to
the clintons or anything I think it's
going to be like we're going to hear
about lawyers and we're going to hear
about um election officials there's
going to be criminal charges brought up
by I mean could you imagine if cash
Patel was the AG right there there would
be criminal charges I don't think it's
going to be like this apocalyptic thing
no ending Wars well Donald Trump is the
best president in my lifetime on on
foreign on for foreign war and pulling
our troops out of Afghanistan setting
the deadline for it I should say Biden
screwed that up trying to get our troops
out of Syria and uh no new Wars he kind
of expanded the Syrian War though a
little bit when he when he did that too
right when we tried to get our troops
out yeah what how so didn't didn't we
send them a bunch more cash right after
that that happen I mean if we are
leaving and and like if you came to me
and said we're going to pull our here
here's what Trump wants to do want to
get all our troops out of Syria and then
we'll give sir some cash it's like okay
but he didn't pull the TR troops out no
no no no he did he he he gave the order
and then the the the officials lied to
the American people to him and kept them
in fair right that that's that's mess
look if if the only thing I could be
offered was vote for Donald Trump he
will take a dump on the floor of the
white house but he won't start a war
I'll take it
done yeah that is a better deal I
considering how many people are taking
dumps on the
floor to be honest Joe Biden is like
he'll dump on the floor in his pants in
in the you know everywhere he goes he'll
have to change his pants several times
he'll start several Wars and I'm like
well there's no upside down yeah well
also none of us are stupid enough to
believe that Joe Biden is actually
leading the foreign policy in the United
States right now right like dude aess 23
they just did a poll they just put out a
poll where only 23% of the respondents
said that they think his mental capacity
is good enough to be president again and
and that's I mean I think that's high I
think 23% is high but that's really low
in a poll for this country well you
heard what uh what Bill Maher was saying
Gavin Newsome's a winner he can win an
election sure uh Joe
Biden man you know the argument from
thetis people that the only reason or
one of the main reasons they don't want
Trump is Trump is a loser he's going to
lose everyone hates him and uh it is
true the only reason Joe Biden won is
because people vote against Donald Trump
I I take that back not the only reason a
a good factor in why Biden actually got
votes was not because anyone liked Biden
but the strong factor in why Biden one
was because activists went out and
collected they mailed ballots to people
and then people were told how to vote
well I I'm telling you listen and then
they told us that wasn't happening the
United States is really big on
politicians failing upwards we've known
this forever and coming from California
I watched Gavin Newsome Ruin San
Francisco San Francis used to be a
really beautiful city when I was a kid
and he ruined it he destroyed it and
instead of going hey that guy really
ruined one of our cool cities in the
state let's get rid of them we said
let's make them the governor of the
state and so we can have a poo maps for
the all of California and next who knows
maybe the maybe the country maybe the
world maybe the world stop there Mars
well there there's a uh there was an
article written SE several years ago
that I had Covered California is 5 years
ahead of the United States uh over the
past several decades whatever happens in
California 5 years later is National and
so they talk about a bunch of policies
you know uh gay marriage was a big ISS
in California things like that uh
illegal immigration Sanctuary cities
became Sanctuary States for Sanctuary
state for Trans kids well California had
Sanctuary cities which then turned into
a sanctuary State and then all of a
sudden you start seeing it spread across
the country and I I think it has a lot
to do with the un uh undue influence
they have through illegal immigration
they get extra votes yeah oh yeah
there's no doubt yeah they they have
extra some some members of uh Congress
have said it's between five and seven
extra congressional seats which is 5 to
seven extra Electoral College votes are
president because of non-citizens they
have illegally allowed into their
country in defiance of federal law well
and under Trump trump said that the
census should be should differentiate
between people who are here illegally
and citizens who are you know obviously
lawful citizens and that's what he was
aiming for and Biden reversed that
within his first few days in office
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at timcast.net